eh bien on dirait que c'est la dernière
vidéo de la saison oui c'est celle ci
c'est la petite vidéo débrief un peu
chiante pour certains est très cool pour
d'autres qu'on fait tous les six mois à
peu près ces inconscients j'ai besoin
débriefer tous les six mois pour me
sentir mieux c'est étrange après cette
vidéo là je pars en vacances pendant
deux trois semaines pour me reposer par
un vrai break avec youtube internet tout
ça va vraiment me reposer me ressourcer
vif des trucs pour que ça m'inspire pour
l'année prochaine écoutez ces six
derniers mois il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses pour moi dans ma vie
professionnelle et dans la vie perso
aussi d'ailleurs mais ça ça ne vous
regarde pas cela ne nous regarde pas
alors tout d'abord qu'est ce qui s'est
passé ceci ce beau décor fait par mon
frère et la mine un très beau brun de
mon frère je me sens bien je sais pas
d'où je suis heureux le parquet sont
bons on passe à la suite envoyé c'est
hyper important le studio d'un youtuber
alors au début tu as pas forcément
studio au début tu tentes et vidéo à
l'endroit aussi où tu joues le soir au
jeu vidéo c'est le même endroit mais
dans mon cas après quelques années j'en
ai déjà parlé j'ai besoin de scinder mon
espace de travail et mon espace où je ne
fais rien de productif du tout l'ancien
espace dragon avait dans lequel on
affirme non incalculable de
vidéos me convenait plus trop il
correspondait plus trop à ce que je
voulais après toutes ces années il est
vrai aujourd'hui ce que je veux c'est du
jackie chan sur un corps de femme c'est
du tom cruise en robe cdu dwayne johnson
avec un petit haut mignon c'est ça qu'on
veut aujourd'hui
enfin bon ça fait du bien parce que sa
marque psychologiquement un changement
ça marque une nouvelle étape une
nouvelle page qui s'ouvre est une page
qui se tourne et ça m'a donné envie de
faire des nouvelles choses dans ce qui a
suivi et ça m'a mis en confiance aussi
pour faire ces nouvelles choses et pour
faire ce que je faisais déjà donc voila
c'était que du bénef céder trop cool
suis trop content quatre jours après
vous avoir présenté ce nouveau décor
j'étais sur scène pour faire le live qui
deviendra le lag le plus vus en france
au moment de tourner cette vidéo et qui
n'auraient jamais dû être le plus vu ce
que c'était mais c'est pas grave mais
c'est quoi la pièce roméo et juliette
rhmani évidemment par nos soins parce
que sinon c'est extrêmement long et dur
pour nous avec mc fly kart wii cyprien
l'a interprété sur scène c'était à la
fois un maximum de plaisir à la fois
douloureux car c'était quand même un
gage à la base je rappelle c'était un
gage de youtube warriors d'ailleurs
honnêtement quand j'ai appris le gage je
pensais vraiment que ça allait pas se
faire tellement ça me paraissait
beaucoup trop chaud à faire en réalité
est en fait si on l'a fait c'était hyper
stressant de réparer tout ça parce qu'il
ya eu très peu de préparation on avait
très peu tard pour s'occuper de ça parce
que bon on avait tous d'autres projets
annexes qui était lancée depuis déjà
longtemps il était dans les tuyaux et du
coup ça aurait dû demander environ sept
fois plus de travail que ça normal
donc on a fait ce qu'on a pu choc quand
même content du résultat et surtout
c'était une expérience de fou avec
malgré tout et cyprien c'était vraiment
trop bien ça a été un peu mal vu par les
gens parce que ça fait beaucoup trop de
score par rapport à ce que ça aurait dû
faire et donc du coup il ya toujours ce
truc de mais est-ce que ça mérite
vraiment autant je ne suis pas sûr voilà
c'était pas le truc le plus travaillé
qui a battu le record mais en tout cas
c'était une expérience humaine
incroyable c'était trop drôle
à tel point que je ne leur ferai plus
jamais alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après revue juillet ben je vous parlais
tout à l'heure de du fait que de faire
un nouveau décor ça peut donner des
nouvelles envies ça peut donner envie
d'aller dans la nouveauté et c'est ce
que j'ai fait avec un nouveau format le
ya quoi voilà j'en ai eu deux d'ailleurs
format qui a pas trop sur et apparemment
rien aura sûrement d'autres c'est juste
que je j'attende bac est un truc qui
m'inspire pour faire un ya quoi parce
qu'il faut qu'ils aient un thème est un
sujet précis alors ce format là c'est
parler un peu de tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment d'actualité et c'est parce que
tous les jours je parle d'actu avec mes
amis je parle de trucs qui viennent de
se passer avec des potes etc et je me
suis dit c'est pour être cool de
parler de ces trucs là mais sur youtube
avec mon audience d'être créé des petits
débats voire l'opinion de chacun je
trouve ça toujours intéressant et du
coup le premier à quoi à hypermarchés
parce que à m'annoncer la vidéo la plus
titrée à quai les six derniers mois
c'est pas grave j'ai pas dramatiser le
truc je me suis dit bon baron ces foires
et ça arrive on a tenté un nouveau
format est en fait ce n'est pas tant le
format qui vous a pas plu c'est plus les
sujets traités de danse est un peu
bizarre de mélanger un truc sur la télé
sans trop approfondir c'est un peu
bizarre dans le fil rouge ce premier à
quoi et puis aussi le montage était très
différent d'attenté un montage
complètement différent de ce qui se fait
d'habitude que ce soit en terme de
rythme en termes d'effets route était
différent de ce à quoi je vous habituer
depuis trois dernières années donc je
pense c'était peut-être un peu trop d'un
coup c'est peut-être un peu pas assez
préparés ou en tout cas mal préparés
voilà en tout cas lors du deuxième bien
quoi j'ai parlé d'un sujet qui me tenait
vraiment à coeur à l'époque du coup y
avait qu un thème est un sujet entre
guillemets dans celui là et pas trois
comme le premier à quoi le montage était
beaucoup plus classique beaucoup plus
raccord avec ce que je faisais
d'habitude et du coup il vous a beaucoup
plus plus que le premier et hormis en
plus parce que du coup ça a donné plus
de visibilité au sujet que j'abordais
qui est le harcèlement c'est important
pour moi d'en parler je trouve que
c'était la meilleure occasion de le
faire voilà très content au final il en
aura peut-être d'autres sûrement même
très probablement l'année prochaine mais
je femmes forcées en faire c'est
vraiment un format que je fais quand
j'ai envie de le faire et quand j'ai
envie d'aborder un sujet tout simplement
parce qu'il faut bien aussi le maîtriser
comme par exemple quand tu quand tu
parles des pyramides
alors que tu ne connais rien
l'archéologie comme on était dans les
nouveautés j'ai aussi pris une
résolution c'était de ne plus faire de
vidéos
gaming sur la chaîne principale ça
beaucoup de gens moi compris que je
prenne la chaîne principale et les
chaînes avec sa pelle squeeze gaming qui
à l'époque s'appelait squeeze là avec
gernot mais en squeeze gaming pour que
les gens comprennent bien que le gaming
se passera là dessus parce que je
voulais que ma chaîne principale soit
vraiment un endroit où je parle de trucs
qui me font kiffer qui me font plaisir
des fois des vidéos qui sont beaucoup
plus complexes à faire que dos des
foules en a qui sont vus comme des
vidéos très simple à faire et
qu'effectivement demande pas beaucoup
d'efforts mais voilà je veux cette
liberté sur cette chaîne là je veux
faire des trucs qui sortent du jeu vidéo
parce que j'ai fait ça pendant des
années et j'avais l'impression de pas
trop avancé en continuant de faire du
jeu vidéo sur cette chaîne là j'avais
l'impression de tourner un peu en rond
je me suis dis bah maintenant je vais
jouer aux jeux vidéo en live ce qui est
génial parce que bat interagit avec les
gens les gens te disent peut-être fait
s'il fait ça les gens réagissent mal se
passer un truc dans la game en direct
c'est trop cool live pour ça et donc je
me suis dis bah voilà maintenant dès que
je vais faire du jeu vidéo est bon je le
fais en live et puis on part sur une
grosse vod très bien monté sur la chaîne
best of et c'est très cool et en plus du
coup ça me force sur la chaîne
principale à me creuser la tête à me
dire bon alors de quoi je vais parler
quel sujet je vais aborder qu'est ce que
je vais proposer c'est moins facile pour
moi c'est un peu plus de challenge ans
et c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté le
gaming sur la chaîne principale
j'ai vu que ça on a déçu beaucoup qui
était très triste que je peux comprendre
çà çà çà tourne une page le gaming qui a
été très présent sur cette chaîne
principale pendant des années mais les
amis vous en faites pas vous avez 100
fois plus de gaming qu'avant au final
sur la chaîne best of fonds s'excuser
mail gaming c'est pour vous cette chaîne
va et si vous n'avez pas le gaming et
ben ne cliquez pas vous aller vomir
après ça il ya eu le faux clash avec
cyprien on a fait une vidéo débrief sur
la chaîne bigorneaux coquillages à ce
sujet là sa demande est beaucoup
beaucoup de préparation beaucoup de
coordination beaucoup d'imagination on
s'est vraiment lancer là dedans avec
cyprien pour pour la blague parce qu'on
trouvait trop marrant ce délire de faux
clash de guerre d'abonnés c'était juste
hyper divertissant pour nous et ça nous
faisait marrer de vous proposer ça parce
que bon c'est plus en plus de messages
de gens qui disaient rassurés squeeze tu
va doubler cyprien oh là là et on
trouvait ça drôle de faire une petite
guéguerre à ce sujet là comme si ces
prix ont été blessées dans son ego une
existence sur ça d'ailleurs et
franchement c'était drôle on en a chié
on a eu peur on s'est privé là les
critiques pour ça mais c'était vraiment
cool et puis ça nous a pas mal rapproché
avec cyprien et ça faisait longtemps
qu'on avait pas tu as fait à ce point
comme ça sur un truc ensemble et je te
marrant voilà d'ailleurs j'ai laissé
pendant très longtemps là la tête de
cyprien sur la porte puisque je croyais
qu'il fallait changer la porte pour la
retirer
en fait non c'était juste à un
autocollant j'ai enfin qu'il fallait
tirer pour le retrait donc voilà c'est
sous les cibles d'avoir laissé ta tête
en plein de vidéos pendant si longtemps
ça n'a pas très bien en avance
physiquement c'est pas ta meilleure
photo tu le sais bon après le clash avec
cyprien c'était le
hit de l'été avec janka avec casa avec
freddy je fais pas trop en parler parce
que je pense qu'on ferait une vidéo
débrief à la rentrée une fois que l'été
sera passé comme cd de l'été bat une
fois que l'été est passé les sons sont
morts entre guillemets et je pense qu'on
fera un débris sont vidéo avec huit mois
c'est une bonne idée moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne idée de revenir sur tout
ça parce qu'il ya énormément de choses à
dire en bref c'est le concept qui a le
mieux marché de l'histoire de ma chaîne
youtube
sachez qu'on est tous les quatre chocs
et de à quel point ç'a marché n'est
vraiment impressionné par sa on est très
content évidemment mais on se dit
c'est devenu un peu virale et ou ccc
impressionnant coiffé de son tube heure
calée millions d'abonnés ont eu peur
quand on a des centaines
eh bien tu peux pas maîtriser la
viralité d'un truc voilà si les gens ont
décidé que c'était cool et que ça allait
se partager et ben ça passe partagés et
les gens vont trouver ça cool et c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec les de l'été
quel truc incroyable
oh la la vache et c'est allé si loin
qu'on a carrément pu faire les solidays
un festival qui est à paris qui est
chaque année géniale en plus de faire un
festival et que ce soit celui là et donc
on a pu chanter voilà notes de musique
sur la scène principale devant je crois
y avait cinquante mille soixante mille
personnes voilà je sais pas trop quoi
vous dire les images parlent
d'elles-mêmes c'était c'était incroyable
c'était fou de voir autant de gens en
même temps d'envoyer de l'amour et
surtout de voir les gens chanter les
gens chanter les gens connaissaient à
mort les musiques qui chanta fondant et
c'était tellement émouvant tellement
stressant avant de monter sur scène
parce que c'est pas notre coeur de
métier du tout mais qu'est ce que
c'était incroyable et c'est pas fini il
y avait encore d'autres surprises qui
arriveront sur ça c'est pour ça que je
fais une vidéo avec avec les trois amis
pour débriefer tout ça mais wow j'en
suis toujours pas remis
après ça lancement de yoko pas de buzz
total d'ailleurs j'ai jamais parlé dioko
moi-même justement je voulais pas en
arriver là devoir en parler d'ailleurs
je vais pas le faire j'ai pas envie d'en
parler de faire un discours pendant 10
minutes pour dire si la meilleure marque
c'est génial tout eh bien regardez on
fait ça bien bleu blanc je suis fier de
cette marque je suis fier de ce qui
arrive
je suis trop content que savait plus à
autant de gens même si on dirait pas
parce que beaucoup de gens crier après
les prix merci à tous ceux qui ont
soutenu la marque ont acheté des choses
qu'on fait confiance il n'y a pas à
l'image de marque est installée et
pourtant il ya plein de gens qui ont
fait confiance c'est qu'on fermait les
yeux qui ont acheté un truc vous pouvez
comprendre ce que ça fait d'avoir un
projet commun avec un frère ou une soeur
c'est émouvant c'est beau c'est un peu
stressant aussi forcément mais sachez
que c'est pas une marque on a lancé il
va rien se passer pendant un an
à la rentrée y aura une collection en
novembre y aura une collection tous les
deux mois globalement il y aurait une
collection il y aura une campagne de com
précise peut-être d'autres et leur comme
le trailer de lancement peut-être tourné
dans d'autres pays peut-être en
collaboration avec d'autres artistes
avec des motion designer incroyable bref
ya plein de choses qui vont arriver je
veux pas attiser je veux pas sûr vendre
le truc mais voilà on fera nos preuves
pour ce que saab a convaincu on va
continuer d'avancer on va continuer
d'essayer de faire les choses bien être
se faire plaisir là dessus et c'est le
plus important
et puis après ça il ya eu balle à la fin
des laves le dernier live on a fait un
petit retour aux sources sur un garry's
mod qui sont la torche et ce jeu
et le pire c'est que j'aime toujours
autant à jouer c'est la fin de la saison
un des lives ça a été une année de live
incroyable la première vraie année avec
une régularité pareil avec un rendez
vous hebdomadaire tous les jeudis soirs
de 20h à minuit je crois qu'il ya que
deux ou trois je dis qu'on n'a pas fait
dans l'année donc c'est très peu on a
vraiment été très régulier et je
me régale je me fais plaisir c'est moi
j'en avais déjà parlé dans le débrief de
ya six mois donc allé voir le débrief 10
à 6 mois vous n'avez pas envie de vous
re manger un débrief qui en plus parle
de trucs qui sont très loin dans le
passé on a fait au total 300 une heure
de live depuis septembre on a joué à 48
jeux différents et on a reçu trente et
un invité différent c'est stade sont
incroyables je trouvais ça reflète barre
à quel point on est streamé à quel point
c'était cool brand stream beaucoup moins
que des gens qui font ça à plein temps
mais il ya cet équilibre justement comme
j'en fais pas trop mais un peu quand
même page et j'adore ça quoi voilà j'ai
rien de plus à dire ah si du coup on a
mis un méga best-of des best of sur la
chaîne gamine qui dure 28 minutes et
c'est vraiment le meilleur moment de
chaque live depuis septembre voilà donc
merci du coup à nos trente et un invité
ça fait trop plaisir de vous recevoir en
live sur twitter et de rigoler avec vous
et de faire connaissance même avec
certains avec qui j'avais jamais joué au
jeu comme joueur du grenier celle du
grenier bob lennon tout ça c'était
c'était trop bien les gars d'ailleurs
bande et l'a vu la reprise des lacs du
coup ce sera le 30 août avec un let's
play
oui ils vous m'avez tous demande est là
depuis un an je reçois plein de messages
de gens qui veulent les dix plaies en
hommage à the last guardian et until
d'inde à l'époque mais si pour les plus
anciens et vous avez raison j'ai envie
de faire les play ça me manque
on va faire un let's play en live le 30
août donc ce sera entre six et huit
heures de live d'affilée sur le nouveau
jeu des créateurs de until down tout le
monde nous aurons plus que je joue à des
jeux d'eau a envie de faire un et
suédois eqt et vous savez quoi on aura
les deux en un donc soyez là si vous
voulez qui fait puis ensuite pour ceux
qui ne pourront pas regarder ça sortira
bien entendu sur la chaîne gaming sous
forme d'épisodes comme the last guardian
etc
et puis voilà et ensuite on arrive à
maintenant du coup bah là là que tu sais
que je vais prendre des petites vacances
j'en ai besoin je me
poser je vais refaire le plein de
batterie et à la rentrée je compte faire
un peu plus de concepts à plusieurs
comme on a fait là cette année
quand on a échangé nos styles et maxence
et les lucioles comme on a fait avec
l'académie des cancres aussi qu'un
conseil qui vous a beaucoup plu qui
faisait vraiment marrer à faire enfin
voila j'ai besoin de faire un peu ses
vidéos là où je sors du studio et on est
plusieurs on a déjà trouvé plusieurs
concepts comme ça avec lui sur la donc
on va aller tourner je pense cash à la
rentrée et ça va être très marrant voilà
je fais un peu plus de trucs irl a
plusieurs mais tout en gardant ce format
là que j'adore ce que je fais seule ici
comme les threads comme quand j'ai envie
de vous parler d'un sujet qui me fait
marrer comme quand j'essaie d'être bon à
des activités manuelles alors je suis
nul à chier et c'est dans mon adn voilà
je veux cumuler ces deux formes à l'art
parce que j'adore les deux et je veux
pas en abuser de l'ain pour oublier
l'autre d'ailleurs c'était un étang j'ai
beaucoup fait des trucs solo ici
pourquoi parce que bat tout le monde y
compris les équipes techniques les
cadreurs les ingé son les monteurs
tourné en vacances alors je peux même
pas le même si envie d'en faire je peux
pas c'est horrible mais à la rentrée on
va rattraper ce retard là vous en faites
pas et j'en profite du coup je parlais
du sol pour remercier tous les gens
qu'il ya derrière les vidéos ne voyait
pas voilà donc la luciole avec est en
bois sur les vidéos avec qui on trouve
des idées et qui est aussi une amie dans
la vraie vie au delà de ça il ya aussi
clément qu'elle a depuis maintenant les
mains ça fait longtemps que tu montres
les vidéos l'a4 en cinq ans il va
marquer la réponse là voilà que les
manques et baky et mon premier et
dernier monteur c'est lui qui a commencé
à monter mes vidéos quand j'ai raté mes
montées moi même et c'est lui qui est
toujours là dont clément un élan bisous
à toi et aux sites et aux meuniers qui
montre les grosse grosse grosse vidéo
parce que c'est clément les monter
lui-même baye aurait plus de vidéos
jusqu'à c'est la grosse vidéo sorte
puisque c'est le prendrais tous sont en
théorie la montée entre autres la vidéo
abad et 1h08 là on fait les hits de
l'été voilà il ya théodore bonnet qui
réalise les gros projets de ma chaîne
youtube comme le court métrage comme les
clips de l'été comme la pub yoko comme
tout ça et puis aussi à mes équipes
twitch mariachis tous qui supervise tous
que soit la technique l'opening etc
yann est des jelly qui sont les deux
moteurs qui sont un plein temps pour
faire des best-of géniaux donc si vous
aimez le gaming n'hésitez pas à cliquer
là évidemment correct aujourd'hui je
suis plus tout seul je suis entouré de
gens qui sont gentils qui sont
talentueux qui sont force de
propositions brèves de gens à qui j'ai
délégué une partie de ce que j'ai
supporté tout seul pendant longtemps et
ça me fait beaucoup de bien et ça me
permet de varier comme ça autant les
contenus de faire vraiment ce que je
veux d'avoir moins de pression
contrairement à ce que les gens disent
qu'on est nul
un gant et dans le top 3 de son milieu
bas on n'est pas du tout un touchable et
pas du tout surpuissant au contraire on
est très attendu au tournant on est très
facilement critiqué parce que ça fait du
clic et des vues et que ça génère drt
j'avoue que j'ai eu des phases
difficiles un peu douloureuse où je
vivais pas forcément bien et du coup est
entouré par tous ces gens basse ahmed a
pas paniquer au moindre imprévu a pas
paniquer au moindre bad buzz a paniqué
au moindre truc qui se dit sur moi et ça
permet de prendre un certain recul c'est
la grosse nouveauté pour moi de cette
année finalement c'est d'être entouré
c'est la grande nouveauté si tu vas
finir sur un mot c'est celui là et aussi
bien évidemment merci à vous d'être
toujours là après toutes ces années
c'est fou j'ai une chance exceptionnelle
j'en ai conscience
un jour tout ça va se terminer et je
pense je n'aurai pas de regrets parce
que qu'est-ce que j'ai été
soutenu et qu'est-ce que j'ai été aimé
alors que vous connaissez même pas je
suis un dieu mais bref c'est incroyable
bon voila merci tout le monde merci pour
cette saison reposez vous bien vous
aussi faites le plein de batteries
éclatez vous bien en vacances on se
trouve
fin août pour le let's play et puis
deuxième jour de septembre pour une
nouvelle vidéo à bientôt tout le monde
merci pour tout et c'est shao
[Musique]